it is weird to see your body change so
much like my stomach like
i've always worked really hard on having
a tight stomach and like
i don't have any more nikki bella is
back on the grind
the total bella star is showing off her
post-pregnancy figure
five months after giving birth to mateo
her and fiance
artem chichvinsev's first child together
say good morning everyone
yeah on friday the 37 year old
revealed her progress on her instagram
story
writing quote getting there she also
said that she is
ready to quote finally start going to
workouts
adding that she's taking on a 30-day hot
yoga challenge
yes the former wwe wrestler
admits that it's been hard seeing her
body change
but when she looks at her son it's all
worth it
no no no on saturday nikki shared this
adorable video of mateo
and all of his cuteness as she fed him
pureed
butternut squash on january 1st
the new mom took to instagram to reflect
on the past
year writing quote thank you 2020
for giving me the greatest gift i could
have ever prayed for
our mateo did you wake up you're napping
you're so happy to see
mama yeah
[Music]
can you say i love you
can we see that beautiful smile
thank you mickey and her twin sister
brie bella
both experienced the joys of bringing
new life into the world
in 2020. they gave birth to their sons
only one day apart with mateo being the
oldest
and brie's son buddy with husband
professional wrestler daniel bryan
being the youngest wow talk about close
cousins
e.t caught up with the twin sisters
after they gave birth in november
and they both got raw and honest
about the struggles they are facing with
their bodies post-pregnancy
so bri you've been there before this is
baby number two for you but how have
things been
different or have they been different
this time around were they harder easier
for your second pregnancy
no gosh i have to say it was easier in
the sense
of i wasn't traveling as much during
pregnancy so
i just felt like my body and because i
had been pregnant before i just
understood it
but my boy grew through my belly button
so and he was another nine pounder
so this time around i actually had more
i hate saying damage done to my stomach
but i did i
i i'm on a very tough journey right now
and it's another c-section
so my abs are gone i have to rework on
those but
so many stretch marks and i don't know
i'm like
i guess next season if we if we get
another season if we film we need to go
my journey i'm to get rid of this
but um i think what a lot of women
they'll talk about getting the saggy
stomach
after birth like even if you get in
shape and i have that
and so it's been a little frustrating
this time around but
i always tell nicole i'm like when you
look at your kids you're like you know
what if you want to leave your little
like marks on my tummy how you came to
this world i'm for it
so they're just too precious to care too
much about this so
it's been a little tougher with weight
this time
i feel like i'm already fluctuating and
i saw baby wait to lose
that's the story of my life so it is
a-okay and that's the story of so many
people's likes which we
love seeing on y'all social in the show
and you guys have been down you've been
documenting your workouts
online for your fans and everything like
that nikki what have you noticed
differently about your body because
honey you were
giving us the deets you know on the show
in real life on instagram as well
so what if you noticed pre post baby
you know it is crazy i like i'm not
gonna lie like when i see myself naked
i get sad at times and i try not to and
i try to embrace like
like when i look at matteo go okay this
is worth it but it is weird to see your
body change so much like my stomach like
i've always worked really hard on having
a tight stomach and like
i don't have any more like i had a
chiropractor here the other day and when
he did this thing to pull out my leg
i felt this massive jiggle on my stomach
and i go what was that i go
oh my god that was my stomach like it
was the weirdest feeling and then i do
look down and i go yeah i have a belly
and like
it's like my legs have tripled in size
and i have a lot of cellulite and it's
like
my arms are bigger like i look at all
these things and my hips are in a
different place and i
was even telling the camera so i go so
my ribs have been pushed out is there
any way to push those back in
like how everything has changed